look at the world around you is it not
more peaceful Avengers let's finish this
hi everyone is Charlie revenge errs
assemble Chris Hemsworth and Tessa
Thompson both just confirmed Thor for in
the last week while they're doing press
for Avengers endgame and other movies
Chris Hemsworth is in the middle of the
Avengers endgame tour you probably see
him posting footage all over China the
past couple of days
but separately Tessa Thompson has been
doing press for a different movie
elsewhere she was also talking about
Thor 4 so I'll break down what's going
on what that says about his art during
avengers endgame with the actual stories
for Thor 4 would be in which characters
would come back because they like
Valkyrie obviously is coming back if
Tessa Thompson is talking about it but
Korg and meek are still alive and if
taiga is coming back which they're
talking about then they would probably
come back as well Oh make you alive what
was your question again so if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the Marvel videos I'll be doing
my non-spoilery Avengers end game review
early next week like Tuesday afternoon
we're less than a week away from it
hitting theaters so it's just gonna get
crazier and crazier we head into the
summer there's a new round of that IMAX
ticket giveaway - all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
Thor comment on the video I know you're
all hoping for beta ray bill because he
keeps getting cut out of Thor movies at
the last minute Kevin Feige he's like
yeah we had him in the movie right up
into the last little bit but we decided
we would save him for a future movie so
no worries I'll talk about other new
characters that they have not done from
the Thor comics yet the biggest ones so
starting with their quotes about for for
this is what Tessa Thompson is saying I
heard the pitch has happened for another
Thor film
I don't know how real the Intel is the
pitch has already happened I think the
idea is that Tyco would come back
remember how we all thought that he was
gonna take guardians of the galaxy 3
even Tycho was making fun of that later
they also asked her where Valkyrie was
during Avengers infinity war and since
Tessa Thompson didn't get a script for
that she just makes up answers on the
fly like ah she was at the bar getting
really drunk the whole time but the
writers for Avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame and the Russos
separately confirmed that Valkyrie Korg
and meek made it off of Thor ship at the
beginning of Avengers infinity war
before Danno showed up with about half
of the Asgardians that they had there
they went into hiding then the snap
happened so about half of the half that
escaped are still alive with Valkyrie
Korg and meek still being a live post
snap they did not get snapped because
most of them pop up during Avengers end
game we don't know exactly what they're
doing during endgame but they're just
listed as being cast members during the
movie
Chris Hemsworth quotes were a little bit
different about Thor 4 basically just
saying that he's going to resign his
conch
didn't come back he said I'd love to
play this character for as long as
anyone would let me of course Kevin
Feige is gonna let him stick around
forever he's one of the few characters
that legitimately lives longer than
everyone else in the Marvel Universe
this is all coming from a recent
interview he did in the last week said
I've loved it so much just talking about
all the Marvel movies but the
combination of this many characters in
this phase 3 as Marvel calls it you'll
never have this interaction with this
many people again who knows what the
future holds and whether they do
prequels or sequels or whatever I'd be
open to anything but right now this is
where we finish up talking about
Avengers endgame obviously because
that's the movie they're currently
promoting I know his talk about prequels
sequels makes it kind of confusing about
where they take the Thor character after
the events of Avengers endgame but
because of what their plans are he is
one of the few characters that probably
survives avengers endgame so I wouldn't
worry too much about that there's just a
question about what he does during
avengers endgame because the movies
three hours long and he's in very little
of the trailer footage we've seen so far
so it seems like there's just a giant
portion of the film where Thor's not
around so the short answer as to why
Thor is probably gonna survive avengers
endgame and continue being a huge
character in the MCU make more films
this is because he had so much fun
filming Thor Ragnarok that had
completely re-energized his enthusiasm
for the character in the franchise
itself so you ask what does this say
about Thor's arc during Avengers endgame
and when would they actually release
Thor 4 in the Marvel phase 4 schedule
because we know what about 3 years worth
of the 5 are going to be in terms of
movies phase 4 is supposed to be around
a five-year plan per what Kevin Feige
has said
you've seen all the Avengers and game
trailers it just seems like during the
movie there's a portion where they
attempt to rally they fail hard and it
truly becomes Avengers disassembled for
a brief part of the film before they
come back rally you have all these
quantum suits and whatever this plan
winds up being where they bring everyone
back from the ashes so the way I'm
thinking about it right now just based
on the footage we've seen even though it
could be very misleading is that it's
Thor disassembled a la Avengers
disassembled before they rally have
their big Avengers Assemble moment and
finally defeat Thanos and fix everything
that he did this is when they would be
able to release Thor for based on the
phase four movie schedules so far so we
have Black Widow in the Eternals movie
happening next year in 2020 the year
after that 2021 it's black panther to
the shang-chi movie Doctor Strange to
the year after that 2022 is guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 maybe a Captain Marvel
sequel so Thor 4 could be the third film
during 2022 in order to hit that release
date they'd have to officially hire tyka
to come back maybe another co-writer
sometime by next year so they announced
it next year they spent a little over
two years writing the script making the
movie they get it out by November 2022
Thor Ragnarok was a November movie and
it did great during that day so no
reason to think they wouldn't keep it as
their third film in which every year
they decide to release it like I said
Kevin Feige explained Marvel phase four
is currently like a five-year plan so
that could either be two Avengers films
sandwiched in that five-year period or
one mini Avengers movie inside a major
characters spin-off film a la Captain
America Civil War where you just stuff a
whole bunch of Avengers in it then maybe
just capped off with one big Avengers
film a la Avengers something something
like new Avengers because it would be
the new roster post Avengers endgame
with newer characters introduced between
now and then so what would the actual
story for Thor 4 be given the events of
Avengers endgame and where the
characters left at the end of that movie
there's only a couple big Thor
characters and big Thor twists from the
comics that they have not done yet and
you have to remember that say like Thor
Ragnarok for instance is the combination
of four different comic book storylines
with a bunch of different characters
mixed and matched so as of right now we
know that there's probably going to be a
new
guard somewhere in the nine realms even
if it's not in Norway on earth like they
tease at the end of thor ragnarok they
could always swerve on that at the end
of Avengers endgame but hopefully
they'll have some moment during endgame
that will address what happened with
that either there is a new Asgard or
they'll just explain where the
Asgardians this survived our because
Asgard isn't a place it's a people force
people at least some of them will have
survived Thor has to officially become
King Thor so I would imagine whatever
the story of Thor 4 is part of that is
his early days trying to be a legit king
of his people based on the events of
Avengers endgame it's complete chaos
obviously half of the universe has been
snapped and is being brought back
remember that that's happening on every
planet this inhabited in the universe
not just Planet Earth so like half of
the scrolls have the Kree got snapped
half of all the other people amongst the
other nine realms got snapped right now
they're doing war of realms which is the
Dark Elf malkov uniting part of the nine
realms to fight against the other half
Thor leading the other half and all the
good characters to try and defeat him
they obviously killed off mal cthe
during Thor the dark world so they'd
have to change that a little bit but
it's always possible that in the chaos
of everyone coming back some of the
other Thor villains get unsnapped they
seized on the opportunity provided by
chaos chaos is a ladder for all you big
Game of Thrones fans they already
combined Gore the god butcher with
Angela from the comics to make the hello
character so you can't really do gore
the god butcher but you can do the
mangog which is kind of like another god
butcher style character the thing about
mangog that actually works with the
stuff that's happening during Avengers
infinity war an Avengers end game is
that he sort of summoned by the spirit
of all the hatred of lesser races when
they're put upon by people like Thanos
or other gods in the MCU so weird God
comes along kills a bunch of their
people they want revenge all of their
negative emotions sort of forms this man
god character summons him and he's more
powerful than most of the gods he goes
around killing all the gods to get
revenge for these people what happened
during Avengers infinity war half of the
universe got snapped think about all the
collective hatred and resentment that
comes out of that how people would hate
the gods for that even though
technically the Avengers will fix
everything by the end of it really easy
way to explain how you unleash man GOG
on the universe going around killing
all the higher beings in the MCU like I
said they've already done Angela and the
hella characters kind of combined them
too but they have not done Kol Boursin
Odin's brother from the comics and they
haven't done Baldur Thor and Loki 'he's
older brother from the comics cole
Boursin though was the big villain of
fear itself
even though fear itself was not a super
popular comic book storyline if you're a
big fan of the deep cuts they're getting
ready to do the Eternals franchise in
the MCU there was a big Thor eternal
saga storyline in the comics where he
went up against a lot of the classic
eternals characters so that franchise
winds up being super popular and it
takes off that they could always cross
him over with those characters like
everybody loved for with the guardians
of the galaxy during Avengers infinity
war a la as guardians of the galaxy
they could do more of that as well too
we got two ships and a large assortment
of morons so me a group we'll go with
the pirate Angels go to nowhere to try
to stop that cool cool so cool did you
fare well and good luck morons the only
other things that we can really confirm
about Thor 4 are the characters that are
coming back so Valkyrie obviously
returning like I said hopefully
introducing beta ray bill but probably
Korg in meek coming back to because tyka
would be the one directing and writing
the movie I know everybody's wondering
what's gonna happen with Loki at the end
of Avengers endgame he did say the Sun
will shine on us again brother so I do
think that they'll pay that moment off
at the end of Avengers endgame but I
don't think that it's gonna bring Loki
back to life I think he'll just be
around like a spirit a la, Odin in
Valhalla speaking to Thor on occasion so
you can bring Tom Hiddleston back to
play the character he can be as
mischievous as ever but technically
he'll still be dead you just have to
remember that for as Guardians death is
not the end hella even though she died
at the end of Thor Ragnarok supposedly
she is probably ruling over there Hell
right now but let me know in the
comments what do you want them to do
with Thor 4 what do you want that movie
to be I'm supposed to be seeing Avengers
endgame early next week sometime so if
that works out then I'm allowed to post
my non-spoiler
Avengers in game review Tuesday
afternoon so just look out for that as
long as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you'll see the video when I
posted all my Avengers endgame Easter
eggs my spoilery review at post credits
scene video all that stuff won't post
til the end of the week after the movie
actually comes out in theaters so no
worries about that obviously a lot of
Game of Thrones happening this weekend
leave all your video requests in the
comments below while you wait for
everything click here for that last
really big Avengers and game trailer and
click here for my Game of Thrones season
8 episode 2 trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
you